now the pandemic has squeezed brexit
from the headlines over the last year
who'd have thought that
12 months ago but the end of the
transition period and the brexit deal
that was agreed just a few weeks ago
are having a dramatic effect in one part
of the uk in particular
northern ireland with checks on goods
travelling from great britain
causing severe destruction and in some
cases even shortages
in shops tensions of course are ramped
up further after the eu threatened last
week to use a clause in the brexit deal
to impose a border
between ireland and northern ireland to
block vaccine exports well let's talk
about
more on that uh we're joined from dublin
by the leader of chinfane at mary lou
mcdonald thank you very much for being
with us um there's growing concern
about these checks between great britain
and northern ireland how
bad is the situation well a very good
morning to
to you sophie and as you say brexit
had dominated very much the political
conversation
not acro not just across britain and
ireland but of course across the
continent
and the globe and the reality is that
the
the deal the final withdrawal deal was
only struck
very very much at the 11th hour there
are specific protections for ireland
they are absolutely necessary to protect
our all
ireland economy to protect our political
infrastructure our
our peace process and and so on and it
is fair to say
that six weeks on but there are some
teething problems
and difficulties with the application of
that protocol so
really what needs to happen is a
sensible informed conversation
between the british government on the
one hand the european commission and
institutions on the other and the
the flexibilities and mechanisms
envisaged in the protocol need to be
used
to iron out and mitigate those initial
problems but
it also has to be said sophie the pr
breaks it was never a good
idea we argued strongly against we
we advised very strongly that there
would be disruption that there would be
difficulties
and really it should not come as any
surprise to any sensible person
that we are now facing into some level
of disruption
and difficulty the protocol flexibility
will deal
with a lot of those concerns but no one
should pretend
least of all the brexiteers who shouted
most loudly
for brexit and told us that brexit is
brexit
um they should not be surprised
at the fact that brexit is disruptive
brexit
is bad news for ireland and
of course it it creates these kind of
trading difficulties i also notice we
know
we do of course your position on brexit
very strong but at the same time like
now that brexit has happened just to
kind of look at what can be done to try
and mitigate
uh the issue as at the you know at the
border and with it with the movement of
goods do you think the
grace period should be extended as
summer's called for to
the grace period for checks on goods
well um mr secretary
safkovic from the european commission
will be in london during the week he
will meet
uh with mr gove and i think firstly
there needs to be
a very detailed examination of exactly
where the bottlenecks are
and i think there needs to be an
assessment of the flexibilities that we
have and how they have been applied
or not um so that's the first uh
job of work and then beyond that
there needs to be a consideration of
what we can do whilst
respecting the fact that the protocol
is now in play it is a matter of
international law
it is absolutely necessary to protect
just the baseline issues
for the island of ireland but i think
all of these things sophie
are surmountable once we have come
and once we have a sensible uh
conversation and i've said i think
to yourself sophie amongst others many
many times
i mean the truth is that um britain
or england in particular has decided to
brexit and and who are we to stop that
although we regard it as as ill advice
but that's just
a view we respect the the democratic
wishes
of your people but equally there has to
be a respect that it breaks that that
was not sanctioned democratically by the
people of north of the north of ireland
cannot wreck the irish economy and the
stability that has been painstakingly
constructed by all of us
over decades now talking about that you
know stability that's been painstakingly
constructed by people the eu hasn't
exactly helped matters
in either has it you know they
threatened to trigger article
16 to stop vaccine exports to northern
ireland that would effectively create
a hard border i know that they roll back
but they haven't exactly you know led to
the calm and sensible conversations that
you've been talking about
yeah i mean i agree and everybody agrees
that
the talk uh sometimes
some days ago about any prospect of
triggering
16 was absolutely ill-judged
um and fortunately the european
institution
stepped back from that very quickly when
they gauged the reaction of everyone um
including
uh all of us on the on the island uh of
ireland so
that didn't happen uh nor should it
um and so therefore i think any talk or
uh from any quarter of some kind of
retaliatory
tip for tat approach uh by the british
government
i think is is just very very reckless i
i think good sense common sense and a
real understanding the brexit is for
keeps i mean this is
a big game changer for all of us and it
has to be managed
in a way that is sensible in a way that
is very none of us wanted
trading barriers between our island
and the island of britain or across the
continent but but
brexit has happened and in some respects
those that advocated this so strongly
now need to to you know very much
uh accept the fact that these are the
consequences
of their decisions and for us on the
island of ireland
there is the immediate need to have the
protocol
work to protect irish jobs and
livelihoods
to secure the infrastructure of our
peace process but also looking ahead
sophie
we have now we face into a very
interesting and a very challenging time
ahead for all of our people because
the constitutional question on the
island of ireland
is now live the issue of partition and
the border on our island almost a
century on
and that's something that the british
and irish political system
need to step our way through very
carefully because we need to create the
ground and the plan
now for an orderly peaceful democratic
constitutional change and direction
okay um just finally the uk's ordered
around 400 million
doses of vaccines against covert 19.
given the shall we say what slow pace of
the eu's own vaccine roll out would you
like to see
any excess doses coming to ireland
yes i would like to see not just between
ireland and britain but but globally
a real sense of generosity and
solidarity when it comes to
vaccination because we we need to ensure
that there is not a reservoir of this
virus
anywhere i mean we live in a global
community so any notion
of kind of a narrow nationalist view
specifically though would you like to
see vaccines from the uk going to
ireland
well certainly if there is an excess of
supply
um in in britain and if there is a
capacity for that to be
shared with ireland at some point uh
well yes of course
absolutely the project here is to get
people
vaccinated and this is as i heard your
previous
contributor remark this is this is a
race
against uh this uh virus and against
death so
so yes i think a spirit of fairness and
generosity needs to prevail in this
my goodness above all all other issues
so yes
is the answer and if the scenario by the
way sophie or vice versa
i would expect that a similar generosity
would be
uh you know afforded to the british
people because
the virus doesn't care about politics or
or
borders or any of these things and we
all
shared the same human biology and it is
so important that the incredible work
that has been done by scientists
internationally including it at oxford
university
um and across the globe that the fruits
of that endeavor and knowledge and
expertise
is shared in the way that that good
science would
that means keeping all of our fellow
human citizens
safe and alive and well